how everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome to another rage game called
super pig which is apparently
exceptionally hard from what I've been
told so it's been a while since I got
angry so why not you know my blood
pressure can take it but my my fragile
mind can handle the stress what not
attention superb oh that's good and has
been beaten haha it's been beaten 1000
times after eight hundred and fifteen
thousand plays good job on getting the
statistics and that's a lot of dead pigs
oh man
eight million nine hundred thousand oh
god damnit screw you screw you game huh
why is it hard
I don't like these statistics haha God
you all suck why would you each woman is
in a very dark place and super pigs girl
is no different
it's like Super Meat Boy I'm trying to
find my girl but super big decided to
save her
oh no - no I'm gonna win I don't care if
it took eight hundred ninety seven
thousand tries I'm gonna win the fit
intro
uh uh what what hey I'm trying to shave
you do you think you're doing I'm trying
to save you all right whatever whatever
I'm I don't carry whoosh I'm a super
okay there's a walled hair oh good ah
I'm through smart for you okay so I'm
starting to get the picture you won't
see the frickin obstacles until you're
already dead haha got through you ha ha
ha yeah hi this isn't too hard I'm I'm
too proud maybe maybe they're finally
realizing my proneness just gotta spray
my blood all over the walls before
they'll believe that I am throwing up -
BAM I'm not gonna like this game mi
dammit
get over that got through it over that
blind yeah ah yeah yeah okay I'm okay
nothing nothing too serious no game over
yeah I'm not enabling god mode that
probably just a troll anyway well I only
have a living over alive you gotta be
joking me how am I gonna do this
oh I see him I didn't see him before up
in the top left this butcher piggy oh no
I thought at least they would give me
unlimited lives oh you sons of [ __ ]
how am I gonna be able to do this this
isn't fair
that's fair how am I gonna be able to
walk come on
that's one do this right this is it fair
it's a bad book no killing small
victories small victories on the way to
a big aneurysm in your brain get a nice
stressed tumor uh-huh the DOM and then
do it hey least I can jump high look at
me oh okay is that in what is that the
enemy pup can't get me on the super pig
suit big scoop pig does whatever a super
pig does can't eat wing from a web no we
can't that spider pig look out here
comes a super pig let's stupid little
things staring at me like he knows he's
better than me he not he is not better
than me and obviously he this isn't even
worth it cuz my super Pig girlfriend
doesn't even like me so why am I doing
this
good I got did I get you're my blood in
your eyes I hope that hurt what is there
a second area up to go where's the
entrance go why am I going at wrong time
Wow Oh No try this way up get up close
as close it was this stop going so high
let go wah-hah Oh
okay I'm up
hang on if you didn't have stupid
limited number of levels or tries or got
stop going so high there I'm trying not
to your stupids that have bent me to
cooperate with I'm not Nuck I'm not good
I'm not good at these games ha ha ha
coos nothing there a third time okay
you son of a [ __ ] I'm gonna get you
okay so where is it huh there's not
gonna be me I'm too professional hey
listen lady I just died like 20 times
for you to say that to me I don't I I
get no respect no respect
I'm not I expected that at least I
expected that one hope there we go
all righty then that's how you're gonna
be up Oh baby I don't even get that many
lives for this one is it gonna be like
towards the end of the game I'm just
gonna have one life and they're gonna
make me have to memorize the damn thing
I'm not going to god mode you have now
entered we're cruising at an altitude of
32,000 we have just entered god speed
verge but I'm almost there almost gotten
is almost too Pro for the likes of this
game up super big super super big super
pig does whatever a super big does kitty
twig can he not die is deferred aha ah
whoa cow I'd barely tap it and it just
blew up into the sky the maze aren't
they all mazes is that really not a
unique name for this type of game that
you're thrown at me I'm barely topping
it I'm barely tapping it I'm barely
there
ah maybe I just got to go in on one go
bath
ah I need to find the most strategic way
possible to splatter my blood that's
what I gotta do all this wasted bacon
delicious bacon I'm trying I'm trying a
beer atomic I'd like the lightest tap
you've ever tapped in your life and I'm
I'm I did it I did it I did it yeah I'm
not activating god mode
well you know I shouldn't be surprised
when I what is that hey you're bigger
now and I still can't get me sudama's Oh
super pig haha let me go well I went the
wrong way
hello Big O you follow me too
whoop oh where am i where am i okay
Oh another one another one you shunned
'm bit [ __ ] sorry excuse me
what are you ha ha ha my dad head I'm
getting better
I'm um again I'm getting good at this
game man I'm like amazing God good
alright that was just a fluke that was
also a fluke I was just trying to spray
my blood and the most up what is that
punch whoa I watch me well in all
honesty who doesn't want me
can you stay back well that's not hardly
fair that's hardly fair
yep but yeah where's my girl
perfect son of a [ __ ] son of a [ __ ]
you shut of a [ __ ] you're gonna get me
yep put one last life one life one life
to live and I Will Survive I Will
Survive oh yeah I know hello oh no I
will stop yeah I am the greatest get up
take all that all you other guys that
rage quick to before me the rage quit I
just had to say something you know I had
to say something
there's gonna be like 10 bajillion
enemies every Oh what we're jumping come
from hardly fear I don't even know why
I'm spouting off about things being fair
it's stupid Jame wise there's gotta
breathe those enemies who just jump when
you spook you yeah yeah boy your boss do
Ju you hey mr. jumpy you go back to your
area I'll stay over uh ah lady you know
what I'm starting to think that you
don't even want me to rescue you
mother mother okay all right the secret
to success is over this way
oh is that mr. jumpy there hope I got
you good stop running that fast
oh I brought a robot super pig this
would be much easier much like Super
Meat Boy this would probably be easier
if I was on a gamepad as opposed to a
keyboard although I did beat the flash
version of super meat boy with all of
the keyboard even the ultra hard user
levels man I can't take this this is
stupid
don't stupid you're all stupid for
thinking it's fun whoever suggested it
to me
joy did have oh no there I wish upon
those who wish me to play this game that
when when they dip their Oreo in their
milk it cracks in half and sinks to the
bottom oh the worst fate I could
possibly wish upon another human being
yeah that's right I went there I don't
even think that's something I don't even
think that's the way to go anymore
come here rub bye-bye
it must be the way to go it's got to be
the way see a holy way that I know of
where's mr. jumpy he's gonna jump up god
damn it you didn't jump your brother
jump uh where's mr. jumpy
where's mr. jumpy what did you do with
mr. jumpy what where's the platform
hello where's your platform where's the
platform
maybe I'm just way but well there's mr.
jumpy found him I don't think he killed
me but I splattered him with my blood oh
man this is brutal this is this is where
dreams go to die
ah man whose whose horrific idea was it
to make a level that only revealed
itself when you die and only give you a
limited number alive
mr. jumpy are you up here huh David my
girlfriend
say bye-bye girlfriend oh come on this
is all a lie isn't it it was all line
that was not the way to go
that was the will then what is the way
to go there's nothing here hang on
and yeah oh you son of a [ __ ] ah right
yeah we're splatter my blood on
something ah ah maybe this is the last
level and it's just there's no way to
beat it gotta be it right right right
gotta be it Oh God one more try if I
lose my mind
boom uh-huh ah I like play the work the
games that are worse for my you know
heart and brain i play horror games we
terrify me on a daily basis and I play
these games and if you just you all just
laugh you all laugh at me being
miserable
hello mr. jumpy glad you decided to show
up I'm I'm not
just gonna you know there was like a
whole other platform I could have landed
on but I somehow time it exactly so that
I land on the enemies that's what I do
that's how winners win that's how
winning is done you'll be willing to
take the hits not be pointing fingers
blaming him him him and everybody that
are you I'm a loser can't beat this I
can't paint this no wonder this level is
called a rage quit lemma did air blame
us in air rage quit I want to die
God why is mr. jumpy up there oh no I've
got no way there is no way this is
impossible and it's all a lie god damn
it it's all an elaborate ruse try to
make me rip my hair out why would you
even want to go down there is that
really the way to go I can't get down
there they can't jump over this stupid
that's all right here that's all a
lighter I don't know but I'm done okay
I'm done this game is stupid and it's
hard and I want to go hug a baby a
little bunny maybe I want to hug it okay
baby
Barun punching them in the face right
punching babies from getting in the face
I want to go home are you guys try this
you guys try it okay you're gonna
suggest it to me you better be willing
to play it so do you try it God thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos since I've
done and as always I will
you in the next video by
I have a second